hi everyone i recently wrote an article
for canada's national post
about the canadian domestic situation
which i'm going to read to you today i'm
reading some articles on my youtube
channel partly because
on more difficult issues i can't speak
extemporaneously
with enough degree of precision
especially for things where i'm pushing
my limits conceptually and so now and
then i'm going to read something and um
that's the reason
so this is entitled
reflections
on the sorry state of canada
i've had the great privilege of
traveling to 40 american cities
in just about as many states and to 15
european countries in the last four
months in the waning days of the great
covid panic
and i've learned many things about our
great and self-conscious nation
first
i have not traveled anywhere else
where the citizens and the government
are more neurotically and fascistically
concerned about the pandemic
it may have escaped canadians notice
but virtually nowhere else in the
civilized world is it now required to
wear a mask
as it is still mandatory damn us in
canada's airports and on flights out of
our benighted country
there is absolutely no excuse for this
except the punitive and appalling
self-righteousness of the trudeau
liberals
what else might you expect however from
a government that also includes christia
freeland a deputy prime minister who has
literally bragged about her colleagues
appalling performance on the economic
front claiming
that it is actually good and meat for
canadians to empty their wallets at the
gas pumps so that the climate emergency
which simply does not exist see bjorn
lomberg's expert analysis
stays
first and foremost in their all too
careless by liberal standards
consciences
i simply cannot believe
that this absolute failure of economic
policy is now being trumpeted
as a positive accomplishment
how daring
how appalling how
manipulative how miraculous
here's a hint
for you saintly
progressives
if you cared about the poor
at all
the real poor
not the hypothetical poor you are
hypothetically saving in the future
you would do virtually nothing but
expend effort
to drive down the cost of energy
energy
which is precisely equivalent to work
and therefore
to the wealth that ameliorates
poverty
second
it is almost impossible to overstate the
degree to which canada's international
reputation
has been damaged
by the childish and ill-advised actions
of our juvenile w e f marionette of a
prime minister
the americans i have talked to
and with
including people very well placed
politically on the democratic and
republican front alike
listen
an open
and disbelieving amazement when i
recount the claim brought forth by the
trudeau liberals and their hired
canadian broadcasting corporation
bootlickers
that the trucker freedom convoy
was financed
by americans
hell-bent on bringing about a january 6
style insurrection
in ottawa
who would benefit from that
even in principle
even if the american republican
megatypes say
cared about us
which they don't
why in the world would they want to
destabilize
canadian democracy
what's the motive
to justify the crime
there is
none period
do you understand canadians
even the american democrats
think that idea
is insane
and a non-trivial proportion of
canadians seemed willing to buy the
story
despite its demonstrable factual
falseness
remember the cbc retraction
buried in obscurity
and preposterousness
because the alternative was the truly
painful realization
that the governmental institutions and
the legacy media organizations
that served us well and faithfully in
the center and on the left and right
for 150 years
have now become
fundamentally incompetent
untrustworthy
self-serving
collusionist
and corrupt
it's easier
for too many
smug and blind northerners
to swallow the line instead
that mad men mega trumpists want to
destabilize
what is after all their biggest trading
partner and most stable and reliable
ally
to believe that confederate admiring
truckers
and is there more than a single one of
those
are working in concert with the evil
orange-haired demon who once ruled the
us
and even worse
is prime minister trudeau
so daft and deluded
that he failed to notice
that these same
mega terrorists
are going to utterly shellack the
hapless democrats this coming fall
and take the presidency in 2024
and that we will then have to talk trade
and otherwise consort with them as they
are the perennial elephant on our
doorstep
and that burning all bridges in that
direction with casual derogation and
outright lies might not be particularly
politic
and the unfortunate answer to that
question is
clearly yes the honorable mr trudeau is
precisely that pretentious presumptuous
careless
uninformed daft
and deluded
but after all
in his own words
he doesn't bother himself with such
trivialities as
quote monetary policy
end quote
third
on the international front
i have had extensive discussions with
political and cultural figures in the uk
sweden norway denmark
romania hungary estonia albania austria
croatia slovenia poland
and serbia
and i know for a
fact from first-hand communication
that canada has hurt itself very badly
on the reputational front
with the derisive dismissal of the
trucker convoy which has spawned similar
movements in other countries most
notably the us and the netherlands
with the imposition of the emergencies
act
and
most signally
with the seizure of private bank
accounts without due process or any
pesky process at all
perhaps canadians are trying to downplay
the significance of all of this
because we are in some state of shock
after all the covid authoritarianism
which we have not yet sloughed off
oh and on that note i have not seen
people anywhere in all my travels
more terrified by their government than
torontonians except perhaps in vancouver
and this includes the denizens of the
almost equally woke as canada states of
new york and california
everyone outside is asking just what in
hell is going on in the great white
north
and not without true sorrow
our country was for many years despite
its rather small population and its
general insignificance in the larger
scheme of things
a beacon of both possibility and
stability
a remarkable example of what a tolerant
modern democracy
might be a place where people from
multiple cultures could thrive
and a stayed
sober
but also sporadically interesting and
creative place
and now
were
shell-shocked sheep
ruled
by a poser
with the maturity of a teenager
and the temperament of a hollywood
d-list
celebrity
and because
three catastrophes
are not enough
here is an additional diverse to use a
hated word selection
peppered with some questions
how have canadians failed to realize
that our government holds them and our
racist country utterly
in contempt
that mr trudeau believes that his
god-given mission is to elevate the
consciousness of his citizens
instead of serving their interests
economically and practically
that the trudeau liberals are perfectly
willing
to make us all poor
miserable and demoralized
just
to utterly fail in his efforts
to save the planet
that the agents of that party and
government are as previously noted
perfectly willing and eager to trumpet
that aim
which can be easily attained
through the wretched combination of
incompetence and moral machiavellianism
that characterizes the trudeauites as a
moral accomplishment
that we could be the freest richest
cleanest country in the world
but that we are trying hard to be none
of those three
that we are dividing ourselves among
racial lines
that are more germane to the us
just to ape the very progressive
radicals whose idiot policies on the
american front
are dooming the democrats to what
appears to be the worst electoral defeat
they have experienced in at least 50
years
that all the data on the environmental
front indicates
that the fastest way to improve the
ecosystems on which we all depend
is to make people richer
not horror
and to do that with good old capitalism
so they have the luxury to think about
the long run and the habitat of their
children
and i have
as of yet said nothing
about additional issues such as bill
c-11
which is perhaps the most appalling
piece of legislation currently on the
books and that's a tough competition on
the canadian scene right now
which renders
virtually every internet content
provider in the world
subject
to the rules that should not even still
govern the cbc and ctv despite their use
of scarce public airwaves
and which will make the rules regulating
the net in canada
the most absurd and restrictive in the
free and perhaps the unfree world
or
the appalling fact of the massive and
continuing subsidization of the rapidly
failing legacy media
are you listening cbc executives
by a government that only requires that
the recipients of that large yes
parent back
every foolish falsehood and lie uttered
by the mad executive branch of our
reprehensible government
or
the fact that because of kovid
wtf
really
parliament has essentially been
suspended
for yet another year
or
that we are pursuing an energy policy
generated by low resolution thinking
marxism adult ideologues that will not
only impoverish our populace by making
energy unreasonably expensive
have you noticed canadians when you fill
up your unnecessary vehicles at the pump
but that will only increase the
probability that countries such as china
will have to rely on coal to produce
electricity instead of accessing say
our plentiful natural gas
and that that will therefore make the
carbon dioxide burden borne by the
atmosphere greater instead of lesser
and
just last week
and in the aftermath of the dutch farmer
protests
that we are trying to reduce the
absolute levels of the greenhouse gas
nitrous oxide produced by those who grow
our crops that's food folks
regardless of the amount of those crops
produced in consequence
and we're doing that by threat and force
shades of covind policy
instead of working with the farmers
to find mutually acceptable and truly
sustainable economic
and environmental solutions
and
that we're pursuing these policies
in a world
where starvation in the near future in
many countries
is not only a likelihood
but a virtual certainty
or
the incomprehensible insistence by
jagmeet singh
sworn enemy of the real working man
that the proper role of the socialist
ndp
is to indefinitely prop up trudeau's
government
despite the fact that there seems to be
nothing in it at all for singh's party
not even the cabinet position that a
competent negotiator
could have at least requested
as compensation for the sacrifice of his
soul
or the fact that our judiciary must now
be staffed by people who must or else
swear fealty to the d.i.e ideology that
has devastated universities and is now
working its way through many blind and
careless corporations that we are in
consequence producing and permanently
instantiating a generation of activist
judges
who regard as their role
not the responsibility of abiding
carefully by rule of law and precedent
but usurping
what should be legislative action
so that they can improve the world more
efficiently
than mere parliament with its lack of
chinese communist party efficiency might
manage
or the fact that the oecd has predicted
that canada
will have
the worst growth prospects of the major
industrial societies
for the next
four
decades
please excuse the elevated voice
but good god
the worst
and for four decades
i believe that the federal liberals
have run
the most incompetent administration
in canadian history
that they have not yet done all the
terrible damage that they are going to
do
that canadians will not wake to the
reality of the situation
because an awakening at that level
requires a level of conceptual
restructuring and consequent emotional
trauma
that we have never been called on before
to manifest
and that trudeau's idiosyncratic
combination of willfully blind ignorance
moral pretension
and narcissistic self-aggrandizement
is so toxic
that it borders on if does not cross the
line
into outright treason
and the situation with sing
might if anything
be worse
he is as dangerously incompetent and
immaturely narcissistic as trudeau
without even being simultaneously candy
enough to capitalize personally or
professionally on his delusional
pretensions
trudeau's government has been racked by
scandals
each one severe enough to justify the
dissolution of parliament under normal
conditions
so numerous
that it is almost impossible to recover
from the shock of the presently revealed
misbehavior quick enough
to process
the next
and
we could have four more years of this
particularly if the damnable sing
continues to ambulate miraculously
without a spine
something physiologically impossible but
apparently simultaneously possible on
the political and conceptual front
this is not good canadians
we not only look like fools to our great
american allies
and internationally and the particularly
self-righteous fools that only canadians
can be
we are actually being fools
led by the king of fools
and we're going to pay for it
and so are our children and
grandchildren
this government
has to go
just as the truckers intimated
and the sooner the better
and hopefully
god willing
we'll be fortunate enough to find some
competent adults to lead us
conservatives
do you have it in you
pauliev cheray lewis barber hsn
can you shake off the mob generated
guilt and consequent moral timidity
that has so effectively hamstrung
opponents of the pretentious idiot
leftist radicals for the last 15 or 40
years
and stand forth rightly
for traditional values of family economy
culture
and indeed environment
can you serve as genuine guardians of
the working and middle class and rich
and successful entrepreneurs and
businessmen for that matter
and put forward a positive and
attractive vision
that's more than mere reaction to the
overreach of the utopian left
conservatives can you withstand the
temptation
to destroy your party with internal
squabbles
or to settle in september
for a candidate that displeases no one
but fails to truly satisfy anyone
as you have done much too often in the
past
rough times are coming
what with
the cascading consequences of energy
shortage supply chain disruption war in
ukraine
energy and last but by no means least
severe and looming food and fertilizer
shortage
the liberals and the ndp are gone
gone gone into the utopian clouds
i pray
we have in canada
something in reserve
that is better
although it is truly hard to see
how anything different from what we have
now
could be worse